Let us talk about Computational Psychometrics a little bit.
Psychometrics itself is a study of human intelligence, of human aptitude,
of human knowledge. Computational Psychometrics for our purposes,
is the design of computational agents that can take the same kind of tests that
humans do, when they are tested for intelligence or knowledge or aptitude.
Imagine that you design an AI agent that can take an intelligence test.
After designing it, you might want to analyze how well does it do compared to
the humans on that test? You might also want to compare the errors it
makes with the errors that humans make. If it does as well as humans do and
if its behavior, its errors are the same as those of humans,
you might conjecture then that perhaps its reasoning mirrors that of humans.
In this class, we are going to be designing AI agents that can
take the Raven's Test of Intelligence. In the process, we will want to use this
agents to reflect on how humans might be addressing the same intelligence tests.